all right good morning everyone
thank you my name is Jess humble I work
for Google and I'm going to talk about
whether DevOps is still relevant in a
cloud native world obviously the answer
that question is yes so relieve the
suspense straightaway so no one's on the
edge of their chairs I'm going to mainly
talk about enterprise situations so big
companies lots of different projects
that kind of scenario if that's not what
interests you there's like six other
sessions going on now and I won't be at
all offended if you're like okay this is
not for me and head off that's
absolutely the right thing to do this
was kind of kicked off because I read
this blog post from devops days Portland
earlier this year where a Graham King on
his blog says DevOps is ops with new
tools I went to DevOps days thinking
DevOps means developers and operations
merged into one team I was wrong I did
not meet or hear from any developers it
was a gathering of systems
administrators who use version control
and righted lots of yam all programming
languages were not a topic I heard
Python mentioned once in parsing that
says DevOps means the veteran admins had
to check in their personal scripts and
everyone is expected to automate more
things they relate to the software their
business runs the way the Merchant Navy
captain relates to what's in the
containers on his or her ship so I kind
of kind of did that a bit it's not quite
right there is something to this and I
want to try and unpack some of this over
the course of the next 30 minutes or so
so I'm going to start with DevOps I
think the best way to think about DevOps
is as a movement that's trying to solve
certain problems so when I talk about
the DevOps movement it's a community of
practice and as a community we're trying
to solve a problem how do we build
evolve and operate distributed systems
at scale so distributed systems anytime
we're talking about how to get better at
building distributed systems we're
basically talking about devil
anytime we're talking about making them
more secure more resilient how to change
them at scale we're talking about DevOps
DevOps famously doesn't have a
definition I don't think this is a
problem there's lots of definitions the
one we have on their site we just put up
cloud.google.com slash DevOps is this an
organizational cultural movement their
aims to increase software delivery
velocity improve service reliability and
build shared ownership among software
stakeholders which is as good as any
I think crucially it's about ownership
of outcomes what are the outcomes we're
trying to create so as some of you will
know I've been working for the last six
years on the state of DevOps report
which is a very big research program
looking into how to build
high-performing teams and organizations
and we found a valid and reliable way to
measure software delivery performance so
that's an outcome that hopefully we all
care about so how do we measure this
there's four key metrics for software
delivery performance which is all the
ones that aren't gray there's two
measures of throughput lead time and
deploy frequency so lead time is time
from check-in to code in production for
any given change deployment frequency
obviously how frequently you deploy to
production and then two measures of
stability change fail rate when you push
a change into prod what percentage of
the time do you have to remediate in
some way and then time to restore when
there is an incident in production how
long does it take you to restore last
year we added a new one availability and
what we find is that availability is
also important and these things together
form something that moves all together
and what I mean by that is when we look
at all the people who we gather data run
what we find is that high performers and
not making trade-offs among the
different objectives and if you take one
thing away from this morning it should
be this high performers and not making
trade-offs among these objectives high
performers do better at stability and
throughput and availability so just to
put some numbers on that these are the
results from this year what we find is
that there's an elite performing group
he's deploying multiple times per day
takes them less than a day to get
changes live they were still service in
the event of an incident in less than an
hour and their change fail rate is
really low right on the other end
there's low performers who are releasing
between once a month and months every
six months it takes them about the same
amount of time to get changes live
because they batch up changes into big
releases takes them a really long time
to restore service and like a shockingly
long time between a week and a month and
you know that's partly the granularity
of the way we ask the questions we ask
you know less than an hour less and now
two a day a day two a week a week to a
month a month to several months so
partly it's the granularity but that
that was really shocking and what we
thinks going on is that a lot of
incidents take a long time to fully
remediates acuity breach it might take
you a really long time to actually fix
all you might be able to get the system
up and running but it might take weeks
potentially to find all the little
problems and remediating and do data
fixes and so on and they have this
relatively high change fail right every
year that we've done this analysis the
clusters have fallen out this way
there's a great listing really well a
great listing really badly and one or
two groups in the middle that are kind
of doing okay so as an industry we're
not trading off speed against stability
the practices that enable high
performance enable you to achieve higher
levels of throughput and higher levels
of stability and availability to
obviously if you're on the low end you
want to know how to get better and so
we've been studying all the different
capabilities that impact high
performance in our research program this
is what we lovingly call the BFD or the
big and
Fulsom diagram and i'm not going to go
through this now because it's a lot of
different stuff but you can i think
google nicole FV a BF d these slides
will be available so you can look at the
slides later if you're interested but
broadly speaking software delivery
performance is that kind of box towards
the right
sto performance with a couple of other
boxes in it and there's broadly four
classes of things that point to it on
the bottom left is a set of technical
practices above that is a set of kind of
management and product development
practices right on the top is a bunch of
cultural stuff and then on the far left
is effective transformational leadership
which is what enables you to implement
the practices and the practices of what
drive high levels of performance so in
particular the technical practices of
what we call continuous delivery and
over the years continuous delivery has
turned out to be a lot of stuff and you
can see some of it here there's
everything from trunk based development
continuous integration through to
testing practices through to data based
practices and then building security in
and even stuff like loosely coupled
architecture how you architect your
systems all this stuff together makes up
continuous delivery a lot of different
practices and those practices drive
software delivery performance they also
result in lower levels of burnout on
your teams they result in lower
deployment pain and they result in
higher quality measured in terms of the
amount of rework you do so not only do
they make you better a software delivery
they make your teams happier as well and
they drive culture one of the themes
this morning is going to be building
continuous delivery into everything we
also wanted to look at cloud practices
so last year we looked at how to
effectively deploy cloud practices who
here
running their software in the cloud all
right great
lots of you that's probably why you're
here so NIST the US government's
National Institute of Standards and
Technology has a very small paper which
defines cloud in terms of five
capabilities and we asked people the
extent to which they were implementing
these five capabilities so quick test
put your hands up if you're using cloud
again and keep them up so if you cannot
self-service the resources you need
on-demand through an API put your hands
down so if you have to send an email or
create a ticket in ServiceNow in order
to go get a server or change the config
of a server or something put your hands
down if you can just run a commands go
through an API you can keep your hands
up all right
broad network access if you can't access
your cloud resources on any device you
want put your hands down otherwise keep
them up okay now the next three and
relatively easy resource pooling if
you're using virtualization that means
there's more virtual resources running
on a small number of physical resources
hopefully that's true for everyone
ruffed elasticity is the illusion of
infinite resources so you can scale up
and scale down that happens
automatically on demand yes and then
measured service you only pay for what
you use
ok good so like a little over half of
you who had your hands originally up
still had them up at the end so that's
great what we find is that of people who
said they were using the cloud only 29%
in the survey actually met all five of
those characteristics so this audience
is actually doing pretty well compared
to our wider range of survey responses
but this is really common organizations
say we're going to implement an
enterprise cloud and developers at the
end still have to raise a ticket in
ServiceNow to get a VM or they still
have to send an email
to get a VM or change a network setting
so that outcomes for developers haven't
changed at all they're exactly the same
and my point is if you're doing that you
haven't build a cloud at all and it's
not just me saying that it's the US
government and that used to have more
credibility than it does now as a claim
but you know if you are doing all those
five things you're 24 times more likely
to be in the elite performing group now
that's the correlation that's not a
prediction in the same way that that's
predictions and there BFD well that's a
pretty big number and we also know that
implementing these practices does
predict software delivery performance so
it does Drive software delivery
performance so in the rest of the time
I'm going to talk about two things
firstly how you build cloud platforms
and secondly how you should build the
apps that sits on those platforms so
let's talk a bit about platforms the
problem with cloud platforms or the
reason why you would care about cloud
platforms is because if you work in the
enterprise you probably have this
problem you have probably hundreds or
thousands of services running in
production so who here quick pop quiz
who here's working in a company of a
thousand people or more okay
quite a lot of you maybe two-thirds of
you 10,000 people or more still quite a
lot of you Wow a hundred thousand people
or more Wow maybe like a third of you a
million or more okay one person up there
it's like Indian Railways or the
People's Liberation Army okay so it's
gone on to his phone okay ask that
question who's running more than a
thousand services in production yeah
probably like 25 percent of you he's
running more than 100 services in
production okay maybe two-thirds of you
okay so that's really painful who's has
services that are in more than five
languages okay like probably about 1/2
of you so that's really painful and
researched by the Foresters and
Gartner's of this world find that about
70% of the IT budget is spent on just
keeping the lights on and adding
capacity to those services just because
and maintaining them is so much work and
now we're supposed to be doing all this
stuff I just talked about CI CD blah
blah blah and the problem is most people
aren't really into doing that
maintenance stuff as kurt vonnegut says
another flaw in the human character is
that everyone wants to build and no one
wants to do maintenance and you know
that's that's ops work that's what
office people do they like you know I'm
I'm that person I like everything to be
tidy and clean and I like to delete
things that's my favorite thing to do I
like deleting things so Ops is perfect
for me
I spent a year working for the US
federal government in a team called 18f
18f was one of the teams that was
created as part of the Obama tech surge
which happens when healthcare.gov went
horribly wrong and they suddenly
realized they need people who were
experts in technology working in the
federal government to try and sort out
all the problems they had from
contracting everything out to big teams
of contractors who didn't work together
well one of the things that we found is
that it took a really long time to get
systems live in the US federal
government once you were deaf complete
it could take about you know on average
six to nine months to go from deaf
complete to life and it was an extremely
complex process you have to document all
the information security controls you
need to implement you need to test those
controls and you to document the testing
of the controls you put a huge
documentation pack together that has to
be approved by loads of people and it
takes months so we thought there must be
a way to make this simpler and when I
arrived in the in the 18f team they'd
already started work on this thing
called cloud dog of one of the cool
things was the we got the domain cloud
that was pretty awesome and what cloud
gov was is a platform as a service which
took care of most of the information
security controls at the platform layer
so if you deployed your app onto cloud
or gov you didn't have to worry about
implementing a big subset of those
controls and it made it much quicker to
go through the approval process another
reason that we built cloud gov is that
when 18f started we just created an
Amazon account and gave all the
developers administrative access to the
Amazon account and we were like just go
nuts off you go which he knows sounds
like quite a DevOps thing to do so I
joined about a year into this and my
boss said ok you're in charge of the AWS
accounts now and I'm like okay so I log
into the AWS console and I start looking
around and basically I'm just really
horrified spitting out my tea just
there's so much crap in there and I have
no idea what any of it does who created
it who it belongs to and crucially
because I love deleting things what can
I actually delete can I delete this load
balancer who knows what networks traffic
is running through that what service is
it associated with no one has any idea
so you basically start doing archaeology
and most of my year in government was
doing archaeology on this account so
that I could delete it so that I could
not be really anxious all the time so
like anxiety driven ops which is the
best ops so in the course of and so this
is a major motivation for moving
everyone to cloud gov was just making it
so we could actually manage this stuff
and not just be overwhelmed by
complexity in brittleness and going
alerted in the middle of the night so
all these lessons are learnt foreign
from this experience basically so if
you're designing a platform as a service
for the enterprise these are the things
that I think you should care about so
number one is garbage collection
there's a whole bunch of stuff sitting
in my cloud who's paying for it who
should I be billing for it in the
government this is really important
because in the government you're only
allowed to spend money that's been
appropriated by Congress if you spend
money that's not in your budget you have
to write a letter to the president which
again used to be something that people
cared about and was bad now sure all
right last for president but at the time
it was you know considered quite a bad
thing and so you have to be really
careful about spending money you can't
spend money that's not in your budget so
being able to build stuff to the
agencies who are actually using it is
super important and then crucially if
you like me you just want to delete
everything so what would happen if I
deleted this is anybody even using it
there's traffic running through it but
does that mean someone's using it or is
it just like zombie traffic from some
load that saw one put in some test
environment number two you want to make
changes and this happened quite a lot
you know we'd build stuff and then it
was set in production and in 18f you
have a two-year service and then you go
off and do something else so by the time
I started at 18f there was services
built and all the people who had worked
on that service had left and now we need
to make a change to that service where's
the source code how do i deploy it these
are all important questions that you
need to be able to answer multi-tenancy
you want developers to be able to
self-service stuff otherwise it's not a
cloud but how do you make it so that
when they do that they can't possibly
impact other services or if I delete
this service it's not going to have
knock-on effects on other services so
being able to have nice safe boundaries
around all your infrastructure so people
can't hurt other people's stuff and we
can delete things safely super important
and then finally just all that
complexity how can we even make sure we
can hire people who know how to work on
this for example and crucially how can
we make sure that all that stuff is
up-to-date so going back to those first
prints
bawls lead time is really important how
long would it take your organization to
deploy a change that involves just one
single line of code do you do this on a
repeat of a reliable basis this is the
kind of null deployment lead time that
Mary and Tom poppendieck talk about in
their book lean software development
this is really important in a modern
InfoSec environment where we have
advanced persistent threats and there's
just always people trying to hack into
our services because when there's a
vulnerability there's this really
important question you've got to ask
which is how long would it take you to
find patch and redeploy all the
applications that are impacted by a
vulnerability and the answer that really
should be of the order of hours and
definitely not more than days there's a
talk going on I think right now about
which talks about Apache struts and the
Equifax breach that happened last year I
think it was last year time flies
no two years ago good grief and what
happened was Equifax was hacked and
everyone's data was stolen not because
someone was deliberately targeting
Equifax but because someone who is just
testing the internet for servers
vulnerable to this exploit happens to
get into Equifax systems and start
rummaging around and be like I mean
Equifax suite let's steal all the data
and that was because there was a flaw in
Apache struts there was unpatched for
several months after that vulnerability
was disclosed so in an enterprise
context being able to answer this
question is really important when a
vulnerability comes out how can I find
all the impacted systems and patch them
as quickly as possible and solving that
problem is going to involve all fixing
all those other things I've talked about
so this is a really great question to
focus on as a driver for building
effective platforms as a service because
if you can answer this question you're
going to solve a whole bunch of other
stuff as well I think the most important
Prince of
all four platforms of service is a
really hard separation between the
platform layer and that a player number
one and secondly making the app part of
that stack as small as he possibly can
like have as much of the stuff happening
in the platform part of the stack as he
possibly can and is a little in the app
part as you possibly can and what that
means in particular say cloud gov was
implemented using Cloud Foundry open
source Cloud Foundry sitting on Amazon
and town foundry has this concept of
build packs
it's like Heroku where you have these
pre-built images for Java or PHP or
Python or whatever and developers don't
get to choose what's in that stack you
just here's your stack you deploy your
app on top of that you don't get to
customize that very much
and developers don't like that very much
but it's really really important from an
InfoSec point of view for example while
I was there we had this situation where
a vulnerability was discovered in in the
Java stack we were able to patch the
whole production environment in less
than 24 hours all those different apps
because we just got the upstream build
pack applied the patch to that and then
in Cloud Foundry you can just redeploy
that build pack to the whole environment
without the app developers even knowing
about it it's super simple so that for
me is the reason to make that app be as
thin as possible
is because then as an application
developer I don't have to worry about
all the venerable owner abilities
hitting my stack and I'm not responsible
for fixing them when they happen that
doesn't I know maybe it doesn't sound
like a big deal to you but it's a huge
deal being able to keep all your stacks
up to date so that you have to patch
this in frequently as possible to keep
your application up to date so what this
means is you have a platform team which
is a cross-functional team of developers
and helps people who are responsible for
building the platform as a service and
that's treated
as a product in its own right where the
customers are your development teams you
want to take as much of the application
stack away from the developers as
possible and then there should be a
self-service API for deployment so that
developers can deploy their own stuff
and so that CI I mean an developers
should be deploying to production and
that should always be done through CI
but again you give credentials to CI CI
can deploy its production and that can
be done in a fully automated way by
using this model what this meant is for
cloud or gov in the federal government
if you deploy a moderate impact
information system there's three hundred
and twenty five information security
controls that you have to document and
test we took care of 269 of those
controllers of their platform layer and
if you're an app developer you only had
to care about between 15 and 46 controls
that made it much quicker and easier to
deploy your app and it made your apps
much much safer things like virus
scanning vulnerability detection
penetration tests that those were all
taken care of at the platform layer in a
fully automated basis and we were using
continuous delivery to deploy the
platform as a service from get in a
fully self-service automated fashion so
we're using all these same principles of
good seniors delivery to build and
deploy our platform so what that means
is going back to those four things I
talked about earlier the platform should
make sure that every virtual resource is
assigned either to an app or the
platform and both cloud foundry and
kubernetes has this concept of resources
like databases that you can assign to an
app and when the app gets killed the
database instances and any other
associated infrastructure gets killed as
well you want to make sure that it's
possible to redeploy any app at the
click of a button
that's crucial so that if there are
vulnerabilities in the app
you can just check the new version of
the library that happy uses into version
control and then deploy that in a fully
automated fashion three continuous
through your CI system multi-tenancy has
to be something you think of from the
beginning so I use something like Cloud
Foundry one of the things that I
discovered moving to Google is that
Google cloud platform has a really nice
story around this Google cloud platform
has this concept of projects which make
it much easier to do multi-tenancy so
you know that's I'm not here to talk
about how great Google cloud is but
there's one thing that I found really
nice about Google Cloud and then finally
to make sure you can manage complexity
and you don't just die under the weight
of maintaining this stuff you need to
reduce options for application
developers so predefined runtime stacks
that the platform operators compassion
redeploy on-demand that's super
important all right
I know switch gears and talk about the
apps so one of the other things that we
researched is you know what what
architectural practices are important
and what we found was quite interesting
when people think about architecture
they usually think about you know
kubernetes and micro services and all
this kind of stuff we found it that that
stuff is not so important what's
important is that outcomes they enable
and these five things were highly
predictive of your ability to implement
continuous delivery number one can my
team make large-scale changes to the
design of its system without the
permission of someone outside the team
or depending on other teams number two
can my team complete its work without
needing fine-grained communication and
coordination with people outside the
team number three can we deploy and
release our product or service on demand
independently of other services the
product or service depends on four can
we do most of our testing on demand
without requiring an integrated testing
environment like a staging environment
which has all the other apps deployed in
it
and five and this is really kind of the
litmus test for are you doing continuous
delivery can we do perform deployments
during normal business hours with
negligible downtime and if you answered
yes to all these questions that was
highly predictive of your ability to do
continuous delivery which in turn is
highly predictive of your ability to
achieve speed and stability there is
software delivery productivity metrics I
talked about at the beginning so here's
the thing you can do this with
mainframes you can also implement the
latest wizzy kubernetes micro services
architecture and not achieve this in
which case you wasted all your money
it's the outcomes that are important not
the technology that you use to achieve
those outcomes now you know I think
human s is great you know I have no I
think all these tools are amazing but
you know I remember doing all this stuff
with bash scripts and CVS so I know that
you don't need this stuff it definitely
makes it a lot easier if you do it right
but a lot of people lose sight of their
outcomes that enables because they're
too having too much fun focusing on you
know getting down in the weeds and it's
important to remember the outcomes
there's an architecture that I think is
kind of quite nice for achieving some of
these goals and there's a talk on this
tomorrow I think which I'm quite excited
to see but it's something I only came
across this year and I've been playing
with and I quite like who's heard of the
jam stack okay not many of you cool so
DRAM stands for Java scripts api's and
markup and the idea is this your basic
static site is deployed into a bucket a
static storage bucket in the clouds with
TLS termination in front of it like
cloud front or some you know some kind
of TLS termination content delivery
network type thing and then all your
static content is served and your main
website
I just set of a static static bucket and
then the JavaScript in that static
bucket called to cloud functions
functions as a service in order to do
any kind of business logic he stuff and
that in turn talks to persistence where
necessary and so you can independently
deploy all those functions and then you
can independently deploy or your kind of
static stuff to a bucket sitting in the
cloud so I really like this and first of
all it's super cheap and very very
scalable because most of your content is
being served from a CDN which in turn is
being served out of a bucket in the
cloud so super super cheap scales
incredibly well and it also makes the
attack surface area really small but you
cannot hack a bucket sitting in the
clouds
I mean it's there's no there's nothing
to get into as it were it also has a
nice separation of concerns between the
content so you can have your content
people checking in you know changes to
HTML CSS JavaScript and deploy that
independently if the code which the
functions are running off so it's got
this nice separation of concerns where
your content team can work on their
stuff without touching the functions
that are doing all the backend stuff
really easily you can figure in deploy
relatively easy to develop and test so I
think this is kind of cool and I've been
playing with it and I kind of liked it
so definitely not the only way to do it
but definitely something that I think is
worth looking at it does have some
disadvantages you don't get to put Kuban
essays on your CV so that can be a
bummer for developers you have to think
a lot about service boundaries and
dependencies I think you kind of have to
do that anyway I'm gonna argue and you
have to rely on your platform for things
like canary release is an auto scale and
cold start and things like that
but again I think actually putting all
that stuff in the platform significantly
reduces the complexity of what you're
building and that's a really good thing
the more you can rely on the platform
primitives to take care of all this
stuff the better a lot of people don't
like that they
it's you know well then we're locked
into the vendor I really don't think he
named I've done stuff on Amazon I've
done stuff on Google Cloud I just don't
see the big deal about vendor lock-in I
the complexity that you introduce by
trying to make things platform agnostic
I think is just so much more expensive
than anything that you could gain by
moving between vendors I just don't
think that trade-off is worth it in most
cases so the more stuff you can run the
platform for the less stuff you're going
to have to maintain I mean anyone who's
like running their own custom database
on the cloud I think that's crazy just
use like whatever the database provided
by the platform is then you don't have
to upgrade it you don't have to maintain
all those sayings like let the platform
take all that stuff away from you we
used to I mean a lot of federal agencies
they won't use security groups in Amazon
they're like we're deploying our own
network appliances it's madness like
don't do that just to use the cloud
primitives so the more you can lean on
the cloud primitives the best right
thing because it's substantially reduces
complexity okay say to concludes a lot
of people think the cloud native is
about installing kubernetes and start
deploying absent yay I'm gonna say don't
do that
I mean install communities by all means
but as part of a platform strategy that
includes a platform that can take care
of not just deploying your apps but all
the services that your apps depend on
being able to manage those being able to
manage monitoring and alerting and all
these other platform level things that
needs to be a fully managed product that
is accessible through an API that
developers can sell service what they
need and those developers have to not
worry at all about you know being able
to collect and aggregate logs and get
notifications that should all be handled
by the platform saying as much care as
much as possible at the platform layer
and give developers a beautiful small
little box that just does all the stuff
they want and don't let them customize
it
you've got to architect for this stuff
both at the platform there and at the a
player
there's a whole bunch of technical
skills and processes that are necessary
to implement continuous delivery you've
got to develop all those skills you're
not gonna be able to hire those people
you've got to develop it inside your
organization you have to develop
capacity you have to provide resources
and you have to create a culture of
continuous improvement I've got another
talk this afternoon if you're interested
in building high-performing teams I'll
be talking about that part of it this
afternoon that's critical as well okay
that's it
questions Oh take a rough
[Applause]